the 144,000 that is spoken about in
Revelation and the question is is this
number symbolic or is it a literal
number the 144,000 are mentioned in two
places in the Bible Revelation chapter 7
and Revelation chapter 14 if you look at
Revelation chapter 7 to start we we get
some real help in understanding this
expression of the 144,000 who are the
144,000 what does the Bible actually
teach regarding them
Revelation chapter 7 let's start with
verse 1 and I'll go through it after
these things I saw four angels standing
on the four corners of the earth well
obviously the earth doesn't have four
corners it's round but four corners
indicate the direction of the compass
north south east west so here is the
angels are standing there and they are
belting the earth they are circling the
earth ten thousand times ten thousand
angels holding the four winds of the
earth now in the Bible wind is a symbol
of destruction debt you remember the
beasts that rise up in Daniel chapter 7
and verse 1 and to rise up as the winds
fiercely blow upon the sea when you look
at Jeremiah 49 for example God says I'll
bring the winds upon Elam or the enemies
of God's people then he says I will
bring destruction upon them so wind is
always destruction so the angels are
holding back the winds of destruction
from blowing upon the earth then I saw
another angel ascending from the east
having the seal of the Living God
what is the seal of the Living God it is
a settling into God's truth both
spiritually and intellectually so that
we cannot be moved the seal
authenticates a document a seal a test
to the authority of that document at a
test to the one that wrote the document
seals usually have the name of this
Euler the title of the sealer and the
territory of the sealer so in a sense
the Sabbath will represent in the last
days of Earth's history a settling into
the truth so we can't be moved so what's
being said here it's saying that that
hold back the winds of destruction the
fierce winds of devastation the fierce
winds that can blow upon the earth until
the servants of God are settled in God's
truth and until they reveal in their
hearts and lives the obedient godly life
that's manifest by keeping the Bible
Sabbath then it says saying do not harm
the earth and the sea - we've sealed the
servants of God in their foreheads the
forehead is the sign of the conscience
the reason the judgment it's a sign of
where we make moral decisions our
choices then it says and I heard the
number of those who were sealed 144,000
of all the tribes of the children of
Israel now in the Bible 12 is always a
symbol of completeness 12 patriarchs in
the Old Testament represent all Old
Testament believers twelve disciples
represent all New Testament believers 12
times 12 144 thousand representing the
complete number of the redeemed now is
this a literal number or is it a
symbolic number the four corners of the
earth are symbolic the four winds are
symbolic the seal of the Living God is
not something stamped upon your forehead
but it's a it's a symbol of our
commitment to Christ and his truth so it
would be rather strange for the hundred
forty-four thousand to be a literal
number and not a symbolic number if the
rest of the passage is symbolic now the
other thing you find here is this if you
say it's literal you come to a real
problem because you say that these are
literal Israelites there's 144,000
Israelites that are saved when you come
to the New Testament after the cross
according to Galatians chapter three
verse 27 and 29 it says you that are
Abraham's seed are heirs according to
the
so we become the church becomes
spiritual Israel Israel in the Old
Testament the People of God in the New
Testament the church is the people of
God so now what about twelve thousand
from each tribe number one that would be
rather strange twelve thousand from a
tribe how could that number be so
precise of each tribe and who are these
tribes that the Israelites have so
intermarried today that even the purest
of Israelites do not know what tribe
they came from so you don't have 12,000
from every tribe that can be
distinguished today that's impossible we
don't have those twelve tribes today so
what's this talking about if you don't
have 12,000 from each tribe and how do
you know it's not 12,000 one from this
tribe and 12,000 three from that tribe
what is this talking about
it is talking about men and women of
every nation kindred tongue and people
the complete number of the redeemed the
tribes of Israel represent the complete
people of God the complete Church of God
in the last days of vers history they
represent those who are faithful to
Christ and so the hundred forty-four
thousand is not necessarily a literal
number it is rather a character
descriptive number it is rather a number
that describes a group of people who
stand when Christ comes now that's
revelation seven now we go over to
revelation 14 and we are really helped
even more in Revelation chapter 14 it's
as I looked and behold verse once a lamb
standing on Mount Zion with him 144,000
having the father's name in their
foreheads the father's name is his
character so these people revealed the
beauty of Christ's character his love
his graciousness it says they sang a new
song why do they sing a new song it's
the song of their experience it's the
song of Moses they've come through the
time of tribulation they've been
faithful to Christ just like when Israel
after the plagues went
through the red sea were miraculously
delivered by God and Miriam led them in
a song so we sing a new song the song of
our unique experience we've been
redeemed by God's grace charmed by his
love saved caught up to meet him in the
sky live through the time of tribulation
it says these followed though they're
virgins what does that mean that the
hundred forty-four thousand only women
not at all in the Bible James 4 verse 4
says you adulterers and adulteresses
know you not that that MDT with the
world is adultery with God so the church
is the Bride of Christ
she has been faithful to Christ she's
not going out and committed spiritual
adultery with the world so who are the
hundred forty-four thousand they are
those with the father's name and their
foreheads they reveal his character they
haven't committed spiritual adultery in
that sense they're virgins they follow
the lamb wherever he goes and as they do
they're totally committed to Christ so
the hundred forty-four thousand is a
character designation of a people that
are redeemed at the second coming of
Jesus and they represent his love and
His grace to the world
you